sciences bonjour et bienvenue dans ce
set up science consacrée aujourd'hui au
marché vis à vis de son petit nom
marsupilami fantasy à non là je t'arrête
c'est marsupilami franchini nommé ainsi
par alain quintard en 1992 en l'honneur
d'andré franquin le créateur du marché
mais aussi de spirou et fantasio et de
gaston et moi je te dis que c'est
marsupilami fantasy
car il a été nommé ainsi quarante ans
plus tôt par franquin lui-même en 1952
en l'honneur de fantasio son découvreur
la classification du marsupilami a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre car à l'est
était l'objet de bon nombre de
publications sérieuse et de conférences
et si la classification du marché nous
intéresse autant c'est parce que qui dit
classification dit évolution et oui car
classé deux espèces dans une même
famille comme l'homme et le chimpanzé
par exemple c'est faire l'hypothèse
qu'ils partagent avance être commun à
partir duquel ils ont évolué donc
trouver à quelle famille appartient le
marsu s'est levé le voile sur le mystère
de ses origines
parlons peu mais parlons bien la tâche
n'est pas facile non marsupilami liam a
reçus comme dans marsupial la famille
des kangourous et des koalas mais le
marsupial a eu exactement comme back
home bas comme une poule quoi et il
porte des tâches semblable à celle du
jaguar et du guépard et pour finir le
marsu est intelligent
ouais enfin tout est relatif
comment défaire ce sac de noeuds et bien
commençons par le début
tout d'abord le marsu a des poils or les
poils comme l'allaitement des petits
sont une caractéristique que tous les
mammifères ont hérité de leur ancêtre
commun
est ce que la dame m'a reçue à l'aide
ses petits le mystère reste entier
mais ce qu'il ya de sûr c'est que le
fait que le marché et des poils le
distingue clairement des reptiles et des
oiseaux
le marché est donc un mammifère
sa caractéristique la plus bizarre et
qu'ils pondent des oeufs
or parmi les mammifères actuels il n'y a
que les équipes menées et les
ornithorynques vivent aujourd'hui en
australie qui pondent des oeufs
ce qui tendrait à faire 10 mars eu un
membre de leur famille
les mots notres m étonnant non que le
marché d'amérique du sud puissent avoir
des cousins australien le fait de pondre
des oeufs peut-il à lui seul vraiment
justifié ça en clair le fait de pondre
des oeufs
il est hérité d'un ancêtre commun
exclusif aux mots notres m et omar sy
non parce que les oiseaux et les lézards
aussi pondent des oeufs et à ce compte
là on peut aussi citer les grenouilles
et les poissons et le fait de pondre des
oeufs est en fait un caractère ancestral
des vertébrés en théorie bon nombre de
mammifères apparu longtemps avant les
mots notres m
et notamment ceux ayant vécu à l'époque
du règne des dinosaures comme les deux
côtés les multis tuberculés par exemple
devait certainement pondre des oeufs
en fait le fait de pondre des oeufs ne
témoigne pas d'une parenté avec les mots
notres m
car il n'exclut pas qu'il ait pu faire
partie d'une autre famille de même y
faire et cela vient du fait que pondre
des oeufs est un caractère primitif pour
les mammifères comme ce caractère n'est
pas apparu exclusivement chez les
mammifères mais étaient déjà présents
chez l'ancêtre commun de tous les
vertébrés
il ne suffit pas à prouver que le marché
est un proche parent des mots notres m
et oui on ne classe pas avec des
caractères primitif
si comme si vous placiez l'homme à
l'écart des animaux en prétextant que
nous sommes intelligents et pas eu cela
impliquerait que l'absence d'
intelligence consciente a été héritée
chez tous les animaux d'un ancêtre qui
leur est commun
mais l'absence d' intelligence et un
caractère primitif et l'homme partage
avec certains animaux en particulier les
primates un grand nombre de caractères
non pas primitif mais dérivés c'est à
dire des caractères qui ont réellement
été héritée d'un ancêtre commun qui nous
est exclusif donc pour parvenir à
classer le marché il nous faut des
caractères dérivés qui témoigne d'un
réel lien de parenté et il n'en partage
pas avec les mots notres m
donc exit la piste mots notres m voyons
plutôt du côté des marsupiaux alors les
marsupiaux se caractérise par la
présence d'une poche sur le ventre mais
les marchés n'en n'ont pas donc ce ne
sont pas des marsupiaux et du côté des
placentaires à cela dont nous faisons
partie d'ailleurs ont hérité de leur
ancêtre commun un mode de reproduction
bien particulier ah oui le bébé grandit
dans le ventre de sa mère enveloppé d'un
placenta c'est une membrane à travers
laquelle il se nourrit via le cordon
ombilical les placentaire sont des
mammifères les plus diversifiés on en
trouve sur tous les continents dans les
airs aussi bien que dans l'eau et de
toutes les tailles et certes mais le
mince eu pour dec petit lait grandissent
pas dans son antre alors à ta ta ta
temps c'est quoi ça ce à quoi bassalah
c'est quoi ça
un nombril alors oui un nombre
inhabituel qu'est ce qu'il ya ben qui
dit nombril du cordon ombilical nom et
qui dit cordon ombilical dix plats
sympas mais oui le placenta qui va avec
mais alors le marsupilami est un
mammifère placentaire comme new hostname
curieux qui pondent des oeufs non oui
mais il arrive régulièrement que des
animaux voit réapparaître des caractères
ancestraux cours dans leur révolution
as oui c'est par exemple le cas des
cétacés qui sont des mammifères et qui
ont perdu leurs poils et leurs pattes et
son retour des nager parmi les poissons
bon maintenant qu'on sait que le marché
est un mammifère placentaire
il reste à savoir lequel car des
placentaires il y en a plein de
l'éléphant à la souris en passant par
les hommes et les baleines pour répondre
à cette question commençons par regarder
les mains et les pieds du marsu ils ne
portent pas de griffe ni de sabots mais
des ongles et ses poses sont opposables
exactement comme chez les primates
de plus le marché se baladent
occasionnellement sur deux pattes
même s'il préfère de loin se balancer de
branche en branche grâce à ses bras plus
longue ses jambes
enfin comme nous l'avons déjà signalé
le marché est assez intelligent il
possède des yeux sur l'avant de la face
et pas sur les côtés du crâne
tous ces caractères sont typiques des
primates
ce qui fait que le marché que par doit
partager à d'ancêtres communs avec nous
c'était même un primate sud américains
comme les singes hurleurs les capucins
les ouistitis les tamarins et j'en passe
mais attention les sages qui vivent
aujourd'hui en amérique du sud
appartiennent comme nous au groupe des
sages sans truffe un groupe qui a hérité
d'un authentique n'est sec
que dis-je année c'est un roc c'est un
pic c'est un cap que dis-je c'est une
péninsule
le marché lui a une jolie trucs comme
les chiens les chats et même certains
primates qui vivent aujourd'hui à
madagascar et qu'on appelle les
lémuriens highlight the move est mauvais
à l'acte de viol actes aux morts
mais une fois de plus il s'agit d'un
caractère prix car la présence d'une
truffe n'est pas exclusivement réservé
aux livres rien elle se retrouve chez
presque tous les mammifères
le marsupilami appartient donc à une
famille de primates à part entière une
famille rien qu'à lui
la classe non alors d'où est originaire
le marsu et bien la plupart des primates
sont originaires de l'ancien monde et
plus particulièrement d'afrique
pense-t-on et on sait que les primates
du nouveau monde
les singes hurleurs les ouistitis etc
étaient totalement absents d'amérique du
sud
il y a de cela une trentaine de millions
d'années mais il y à 30 millions
d'années
ces derniers ont traversé l'atlantique
qui était en cours d'ouverture
ils ont certainement réalisé cette
traversée sur des sortes de radio
naturel flottant constitué de branchages
de troncs d'arbres et de divers débris
arrachés durant deux puissantes cru et
on voyait avec une force colossale dans
les océans par les inondations 2 telle
radio aujourd'hui peuvent atteindre la
taille d'une petite île est préservé
pour un herbivore ou un affectivement
suffisamment de nourriture pour tenir
tout le long de la traversée
poussé par le courant des alizés
invraisemblable croyez vous et bien
sachez qu'à peu près à la même époque
il est arrivé la même chose aux ancêtres
des rongeurs qui peuplent aujourd'hui
l'amérique du sud
il n'est donc pas hasardeux de faire
l'hypothèse qu'il est arrivé la même
chose aux ancêtres dumas reçus au
passage m'a reçue possède effectivement
à cousin africain marsupilami africanus
qui a continué à évoluer sur place sur
la terre natale des marsupilamis c'est
ce cap sciences est terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi désormais vous savez tout
de l'origine et de l'évolution du
marsupilami
alors content avec plaisir pour en
savoir plus sur la classification
phylogénétique dix vivant nous vous
conseillons de consulter le livre qui
porte ce titre et pour tout savoir du
marché lisez les bd merci à tous